The foot detox bath. How many times a week? Um, the reason we don't specify
because some people don't do it at all. Some people do it every day. So it
really has to do with your time. How much time do you have? So um, what's
reasonable? Okay, I have all the time in the world. I'm retired. I don't have
anything else to do. And I don't mind doing it. I just sit there and watch TV. Well,
then do it every day. Um, but some people are like, Oh my gosh, it's just
another thing to do. And if I do that, that I don't have time to do my son or
I don't have your way in between things like that, then you do have to
kind of make a decision. I'll be honest with you, I never did the foot bath. I
just never did it. Um, it's like, I just did not feel led to do that.
And you know, some people really feel led to do that. I think it's a great tool,
but I'm just being honest with you guys. I didn't do it. I'm just too
um, ADD, ADHD, I couldn't sit there if I put it in a bath.
I can't go on vacation with my wife, because I'll sit down at the pool and
probably say we're going to sit at the pool and just get a relax. I can sit there
five minutes without thinking, oh, goodness, six. I'm going to get my book on tape and
and study. I got to go study and I got to go, you know,
I can't do it. I'm just too ADHD. That's just the way god made me. I just got to
do that. I just get to sit there. That's just me. So